ce petit chemin mais c'était c'était un
chemin de terre autrefois des cailloux
n'y avait que des cailloux que des
cailloux germain grégoire marche sur les
traces de son passé celui d'une enfance
volée au détour de ce chemin du quartier
redoute à fort de france
après douze ans de recherche c'est un
lointain camarades d'enfance qui l'a
amené sur la piste des ruines de cette
maison celle de sa mère
où lui et ses deux frères ont été
enlevés il ya 63 ans maintenant
il avait huit ans
la vérité desbarats et le mensonge par
dc nous sommes sur les lieux où nous
avons disparu en 1956 le 24 février 1956
c'est la première fois que c'est la
première fois sa faim depuis 2007 que je
recherche
cet endroit le 24 février 56
nous sommes assis tous là à table nous
sommes à table nous mangeons
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je ne peux
rien dire à personne ce qui s'est passé
c'est le trou droit en se réveille dans
un champ complètement drogué
complètement drogué les trois garçons ou
son nous serons sais pas les trois
garçons deux inconnus amène alors les
trois frères au port de fort de france
pour rejoindre le paquebot colombie
la passerelle est remonté et leur
nouveau diamant
et puis nous voyons arriver dans ce
revers elle arrive
hurle en vole mes enfants me voient
comme une tempête et des semaines de
traversée plus tard les voilà arrivés au
havre
c'est d'abord le froid terrible qui les
accueillent
puis une tante rachel carassus qui
aurait tramer cette sinistre opération
direction les hautes pyrénées où les
trois frères seront balade et
d'orphelinats en orphelinat à 12 ans le
jeune germain travail à la ferme puis
comme apprenti boulanger des années de
souffrance et de brimades tous et nous
était interdit on n'avait pas grave et
on est même pas des français la tour
nous étions en duo avec un vieux en
fréquenter que des vieux tout avait
pourtant bien commencé ici aux terres
sainville où vivait la famille de cinq
enfants trois garçons et deux filles et
des parents pas encore divorcé alors
pourquoi que s'est il passé
une multitude de questions qui hantent
littéralement charmé les gloires
c'est un homme malheureux c'est une
famille détruite penser que si ça
pouvait vous arrivez messieurs dames
pensez à vos enfants comment y serez
vous nous devez la vérité vous devez la
vérité
rendez nous la vérité parekh à tous les
hommes politiques tous sans exception
tous source
en france comme en martinique
après un livre des centaines de
documents d'archivés accumulés et malgré
le décès de nombreux protagonistes
germain grégoire ne connaît toujours pas
le repos à 72 ans il veut la vérité
comme une promesse à la mémoire de sa
mère
[Musique]